[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend alles
Wichtige vom Sport an diesem Sonntag hat
Rudi Cerne für Sie hallo auch von mir
schönen guten Abend unser Blick auf die
Themen
Zwischenfall vor Taiwan die USA werfen
einem chinesischen Kriegsschiff
gefährliche Annäherung vor
Peking warnt das Ausland vor Einmischung
Hinweis auf Unglücksursache laut Indiens
Regierung ist ein fehlerhaftes Signal
für die verhängnisvolle Kollision von
drei Zügen verantwortlich
und Party mit DFB-Pokal die Spieler von
RB Leipzig werden in der Heimat von
tausenden begeisterten Fans empfangen
[Musik]
China und die USA Ringen im asiatischen
pazifischen Raum um Einfluss jetzt hat
der chinesische Verteidigungsminister
Lee Chang Fu vor US-geführten
Militärbündnissen nach dem Vorbild der
NATO in der Region gewahrt die Aussagen
machte er bei einer Sicherheitskonferenz
in Singapur die Spannungen nehmen zu
größter Konfliktpunkt ist Chinas Umgang
mit Taiwan Peking betrachtet das
demokratische Taiwan als Teil der
Volksrepublik und strebt eine
Vereinigung an notfalls mit Gewalt erst
gestern waren sich in der Regionen
internationalen Gewässern zwei
Marineschiffe der USA und Chinas
gefährlich nahe gekommen Thomas Reichert
berichtet
es ist ein Vorfall der beinahe zu einem
Konflikt geführt hätte ein
amerikanisches Kriegsschiff fährt durch
die Straße von Taiwan internationale
Gewässer ein chinesisches Kriegsschiff
will es offenbar vertreiben schneidet
dem US-Zerstörer von links kommen den
Weg ab nur knapp 130 Meter fehlen am
Ende zu einer Kollision am Tag danach
wird chines Verteidigungsminister
liefern vor in Singapur gefragt warum
gefährdet Chinas Militär das Leben
seiner und anderer Soldaten seine
Antwort gerichtet an die USA
was habt ihr dort zu suchen wir sagen
immer kümmert euch um eure eigenen
Angelegenheiten und passt gut auf auf
eure Leute Marineschiffe und Kampfjets
kaum je zuvor trat ein mächtiger Pekings
auf internationale Bühne so scharf und
konfrontativ auf ein Treffen mit den USA
lehnte er ab es gab nur einen kurzen
handydruck beim Dinner
um es klar zu sagen antwortet der
US-Verteidigungsminister wir suchen
nicht den Konflikt oder die
Konfrontation aber wir werden nicht vor
Mobbing oder Zwang zurückschrecken China
fordert hier in Singapur nichts weniger
als freie Hand in Südostasien das ist
eine Kampfansage an die USA sich aus der
Region zurückzuziehen und es zeigt ein
bisschen kaum gekanntes Maß an
Konfrontation zwischen den beiden
Supermächten
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius rief in
Singapur zum Schutz der auf Regeln
basierenden internationalen Ordnung auf
dafür werde Deutschland im kommenden
Jahr zwei Kriegsschiffe in die Region
schicken
mindestens 500 ukrainische Kinder seien
seit Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges getötet worden das sagte
Präsident selenski russische Waffen und
russische Hass zerstörten jeden Tag das
Leben ukrainischer Kinder bei einem
nächtlichen Angriff auf ein Wohnviertel
nah der Stadt deni pro kam ein
zweijähriges Mädchen ums Leben 22
weitere Menschen wurden ukrainischen
Angaben zufolge verletzt
es ist ein Tag der Trauer in Indien aber
auch ein Tag voller Fragen wie kann es
sein dass ein Signalfehler ausreicht um
ein so verheerendes Zugunglück
auszulösen
275 Menschen wurden getötet bis zu 1.000
verletzt dabei war viel Geld ins
veraltete Bahnsystem investiert worden
doch auf der unglückstrecke war das
automatische antikollisionssystem noch
nicht installiert Thomas gonzio
berichtet
zermalmtes Metall und Trümmer überall
auch am Tag 3 helfen zwischen
fortgeschleuderten Waggons sogar
freiwillige teils mit bloßen Händen
Bergungsarbeiten Spurensuche neue
Erkenntnisse
eine Änderung im elektronischen
Stellwerk hat den Unfall verursacht wer
das getan hat und warum wird die
Untersuchung zeigen
das Unglück mit zwei passagierbanen und
einem Güterzug geschah Freitagabend wer
es überlebte wartet in den völlig
überfüllten Krankenhäusern auf Hilfe es
sind hunderte mit furchtbaren Wunden und
leiden
meine Tochter wurde von einem riesigen
Stück Stahl erdrückt das Eisen war zu
schwer sie zu befreien sie weinte und
starb direkt vor meinen Augen
sie haben nicht einmal die Gewissheit ob
ihre Angehörigen noch leben Menschen
Wangen vor Leichenhallen gleichen Fotos
ab Hoffnung und Verzweiflung nah
beieinander
simaderie sucht ihren Ehemann
ich war in allen Krankenhäusern und habe
ihn nicht gefunden
aber auch hier ist er nicht Simas Suche
geht weiter eines von vielen Schicksalen
nach dem indischen Zugunglück
nach Demonstrationen und Zusammenstößen
zwischen Polizei und linken Gruppen in
Leipzig üben SPD und Linke Kritik am
Verhalten der Polizei
eigenen Angaben zur Folge kesselte die
Polizei am Abend rund 1.000 Menschen ein
und hebt sie teilweise über Stunden fest
im Stadtteil Connewitz attackierten
demonstrierende Einsatzkräfte und
setzten Barrikaden in Brand laut Polizei
wurden am Wochenende knapp 30 Menschen
festgenommen und etwa 50 Polizisten
verletzt Anlass für die Proteste war das
Urteil gegen die Studentin Lina Ehe
wegen Überfällen auf rechtsextreme
bundesinnenministerin Feser hat sich
bestürzt gezeigt über den Tod eines
Kindes bei einem Brand in einer
Flüchtlingsunterkunft in Thüringen ihr
ganzes Mitgefühl gelte der Familie und
den geflüchteten das Feuer in dem Heim
in Apolda war aus bislang ungeklärter
Ursache am frühen Morgen ausgebrochen
250 Menschen mussten evakuiert werden
zehn von ihnen kamen verletzt ins
Krankenhaus ein neunjähriger Junge aus
der Ukraine wird vermisst aber sich um
das tote Kind handelt ist noch nicht
sicher
in Polen haben heute hunderttausende
Menschen gegen die Politik der
Nationalkonservativen Regierungspartei
peace protestiert zu der Demonstration
hatte die Opposition aufgerufen auch
wegen eines neuen Gesetzes dass der
peace-regierung ermöglicht
Oppositionspolitiker und Politikerinnen
von öffentlichen Ämtern auszuschließen
wegen angeblicher russlandfreundlichkeit
im Herbst wird ein neues Parlament
gewählt über den Protest berichtet
Svenja bergerhoff
Seite an Seite zeigt sich der polnische
Ex-Premier und aussichtsreichste
oppositionskandidat Donald TuS mit welch
wabausa der Symbolfigur für das Ende des
Kommunismus in Polen ein Zeichen zum
Jahrestag der ersten teilweise freien
Wahl 1989 die Opposition ruft zum
Protest
der erste Schritt zum Sieg ist es unsere
Stärke zu zeigen
hunderttausende sind dafür heute
gekommen
ich möchte Freiheit für mich und für
zukünftige Generationen
ich habe Zweifel ob die nächsten Wahlen
wirklich legal ablaufen werden
Auslöser für die Zweifel und den großen
Andrang ein neues Gesetz letzte Woche
von Präsident duda unterzeichnet eine
Kommission soll den Einfluss Russlands
auf die Politik der vergangenen Jahre
untersuchen und könnte Personen von
öffentlichen Ämtern ausschließen die
Opposition ist sich in ihrer Antwort
einig
wir werden bei dieser
verfassungswidrigen Farce nicht
mitmachen das kann ich Ihnen sagen
Kritiker befürchten die
nationalkonservative Regierungspartei
peace wolle so ihren autokratischen Kurs
fortsetzen und vor allem einen ins
schlechte Licht rücken Donald Tusk
attestiert man ihm Russland freundliches
Handeln in seiner Regierungszeit könnte
er zwar bei der Wahl im Herbst als
Spitzenkandidat antreten dürfte aber bei
einem Sieg nicht Premierminister werden
nach Kritik aus dem Ausland kündigt
Präsident du da an das Gesetz
überarbeiten zu wollen gesichert ist das
aber nicht
und wir kommen zum Sport in Leipzig
nämlich wurde auch friedlich gefeiert
und vor allem fröhlich und die Leipziger
Fußballfans hatten allen Grund dazu
Titelverteidigung geglückt RB Leipzig
gründlich erneut zum DFB-Pokalsieger
nach dem 2:0 Siegtreffer von Dominik
soboslai begann der Feiermarathon
Kapitän Willi Orban mit dem Pokal in den
Händen und danach auf der
Pressekonferenz machten die Leipziger
ihren Trainer Rose nass und wie und
heute in Leipzig ging und geht es
natürlich weiter Steffi Moritz Müller
wie ist denn die Stimmung vor Ort und
was ist denn schon passiert
ja also die heutige Siegesfeier der
Mannschaft begann etwas förmlich mit dem
obligatorischen Eintrag ins Goldene Buch
der Stadt aber danach ging es ans feiern
zuerst auf den brückenbalkon in der
Innenstadt da präsentierte die
Mannschaft denn Fans die den Pokal und
die Fans begleiten dann anschließend
ihre Mannschaft auf dem offenen Bus der
quer durch die Stadt so Richtung Stadion
und auch im Stadion auf der Festwiese
davor warteten nochmal tausende Fans und
wollten ihre Mannschaft begrüßen jetzt
stehen wir hier die Party ist vorbei es
ist gerade mit dem Aufräumen begonnen
worden aber noch vor einer Stunde
standen hier geschätzt 25.000 Fans und
bejubelten ihre Mannschaft ihre roten
Bullen ihren Pokal den Marco Rose zum
Schluss auf die Bühne brachte und die
ganze Zeit über hörte man den neuen
Slogan der rb-fans der seit gestern
Abend gilt zweimal Leipzig immer Leipzig
heißt nächstes Jahr gleiche Stelle
gleicher Ort gleiche Zeit wollen sie
ihre Mannschaft wieder feiern vielen
Dank Steffi
Formel 1 Weltmeister Max Verstappen hat
auch den Großen Preis von Spanien
gewonnen mit einem nie gefährdeten Stadt
zielsieg deklarierte der Niederländer
die Konkurrenz hatte bei seinem fünften
Saison Sieg am Ende 24 Sekunden
Vorsprung auf Luis Hamilton john Russell
wurde dritter Nico Hülkenberg schaffte
es als 15 nicht in die Punkte bringen
so und Alexander Zverev steht im
Achtelfinale der French Open der Tennis
Olympiasieger setzte sich in der Nacht
zum Sonntag gegen den Amerikaner Francis
thia Phone nach drei Stunden und 41
Minuten mit drei zu sechs sieben zu
sechs sechs zu eins und sieben zu sechs
durch damit steht der 28-Jährige beim
Grand Slam Turnier in Paris zum sechsten
Mal nacheinander in der Runde der
letzten 16
das war's von mir für heute danke schön
Rudi sehr gerne
und so wird das Wetter im Südosten sind
die Wolken meist dicht und es gibt
Schauer und Gewitter einzelne Schauer
kann es auch im Schwarzwald geben sonst
scheint die Sonne die Höchstwerte liegen
zwischen 19 und 28 an der Nordsee bei 16
Grad
eine gallinek Interview um 21:45 Uhr im
heute journal CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz
und jetzt geht's weiter mit Berlin
direkt mit Theo Koi vielen Dank Jana
pareignis die rechtsradikale AFD ist in
den Umfragen jetzt auf Augenhöhe mit der
Kanzlerpartei SPD in Sachsen und
Thüringen liegt sie sogar auf Platz 1
und die anderen Parteien sind
wechselweise Rat oder fassungslos das
ist eines unserer Themen heute und damit
herzlich Willkommen zu Berlin direkt